christophe tison bonsoir que c'est une
rente gmail bouras les na li nina
benjamin biolay jean paul rouve michaël
youn à la chamade laurent baffie visite
votre livre était bouleversant c'est
vrai que ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas lu un truc aussi aussi fort
ça s'appelle il m'aimait oui et c'est
publié chez grasset alors d'abord on va
dire qui vous êtes avait 42 ans
vous êtes rédac chef au service culture
à canal+ et haï télévision et vous avez
déjà publié deux bouquins la drogue
expliquer aux parents chez balland il ya
deux différences
oui nos enfants préfèrent et l'air dû
vite
toujours chez balland ouais alors on
revient il m'aimait il
c'est un adulte qui était amoureux de
l'enfant que vous étiez et le livre
raconte comment son amour parce que
c'était de l'amour comment son amour
vous a détruit oui oui c'est vrai alors
comme le fait remarquer notre ami
frédéric beigbeder dans voici
d'habitude la littérature abordé le
sujet de la de la pédophilie par l'angle
du narrateur pédophile c'est nabokov
dans le lit tu as et rose bonbon c'est
il entrerait dans la légende et en
général quand c'est des victimes qui
témoigne c'est plutôt des témoignages
assez moureaux assez vertueux est là
pour la première fois c'est toujours
beigbeder qui parle il dit il on ose
dire oui les enfants sont attirés par
les adultes
il aime quand les cajole voilà
évidemment le ska de très nouveau et à
la fois de très de très choquant mais de
très vrai dans votre livre c'est qu'en
fait l'enfant que vous étiez aimé
j'irai pas son bourreau enfin aimer son
amant d'une certaine façon il était
attiré par lui si oui c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu le syndrome de stockholm où
c'est
c'est quand un adulte prends soin de toi
finalement tulle m quoi il ya un truc un
truc très fort ouais il remplace ton
père en place ta mère et puis et puis
finalement ben tu tu ne peux pas
t'empêcher de l'aimer jusqu'au moment où
vient le soir nous te retrouves dans le
lit avec lui ou là c'est horrible ouais
alors vous dit j'aurais dû refuser d'y
aller et pourtant c'est bien moi qui
retournait le voir c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il vous embrassez vous
cajoler il vous prodiguer de l'amour il
s'intéressait à vous et vous étiez d'une
certaine façon en tiré par lui-même pour
dire les choses crûment
bah oui il avait une énorme un énorme
sexe et puis moi j'étais tout petit j'ai
eu moi j'ai une fille qui a 9 ans ça a
commencé quand j'avais 9 ans je me dis
mais qu'est ce que ces petits quoi c'est
hallucinant et et this et je n'arrive
pas j'arrive pas à me faire et bon
finalement c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'il m'est même que je lai
et finalement il me faisait mal géré
dans le livre c'est vraiment très
étonnant et très choquant moi j'ai eu
vraiment du mal tu sors j'ai du mal à
dire oui mais là vraiment c'est très
fort
ce qui est terrible ce qui est terrible
dans le book
cette ambivalence est à dire que celui
qui vous fait le plus de mal est
également celui qui vous fait le plus de
bien une certaine façon ouais c'est vrai
nom c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'était un
type génial parce que je vais pas faire
je vais pas faire son apologie
aujourd'hui mais c'était quand même un
type génial parce que il ne faisait lire
il me faisait il faisait lire boris vian
il faisait lire sartre etc
des lectures que j'aurais jamais eu si
j'avais été sans lui il me projeter des
films
jali dans des cinémas vase au mini vous
emmener pas omis le décaméron il
projetait il me projetais caisse il me
projetais d'aider tout tout tout les
lauzes et et il était incroyable avec
moi
vraiment il était incroyable de d'amour
de tendresse de bon et le problème c'est
que après je le paye est quoi billie
jean
alors jusqu'au 20 mai mais j'y pense
fortement à chaque fois qu'il joue à
michael jackson j'y pense c'est sûr il
faut dire à nos amis téléspectateurs que
cette histoire se passe quand même aux
pires moments de l'époque bakou le post
soixante huitarde
c'est l'époque la sexualité n'a pas de
règles piles et les drogues partout sur
votre mère fumer des pétards devant vous
c'était l'époque de la permissivité mes
pots cassés libertaire naturiste les
enfants sont livrés à eux-mêmes donc
ouais mais c'était en même temps c'était
une époque geignard c'était absolument
génial moi j'adorais je me tremblay
avait dans une petite ville dans une
espèce de traction avant vert pomme et
cetera avec des mecs avec des cheveux
longs temps et tout c'était génial parce
que tous les gens de la ville
c'était à beaune en bourgogne
on ne peut pas dire le nom de la ville
et puis tous les gens d'avis disait mais
qui sait c'est horrible hippie et moi je
trouvais ça génial
là je trouve cette revue qui d'une
certaine façon leur la bonne petite
bourgeoisie provinciale
exactement voilà alors au début donc
effectivement vous avez 8 9 ans et c'est
fou parce que moi aussi j'ai un fils
kaka 8 en voilà et donc le mec s'appelle
didier il est projectionniste dans la
troupe de théâtre commenter votre votre
père et parents à beaune et vous
raconter la première fois vous dites il
m'a fait la chose sans nom c'est que là
on est vraiment dans l'indicible c'est à
dire que vous au départ vous savez même
pas ce qu'est le sperme bout quoi qu'il
vous pisse dessus donc non mais c'est
foutu nation c'est à dire que vous ne
mangez pas donné de détails trop
scabreux parce qu'effectivement on n'est
pas fait pour ça pour le lait c'est vrai
que vous n'y connaissez rien quand il
commande non mais pour pour le dire pour
le dire crûment c'est vrai que il me
prend la main il me la met sur sa [ __ ]
et je sens un truc mouiller je me dis
mais [ __ ] il a pissé c'est horrible
c'est vraiment dégueulasse
enfin bon et
et
et ça prouve combien j'étais petit quoi
combien j'étais passé ce qui est
terrible en fait dans cette histoire
c'est que le plaisir que vous prenez pas
ce que vous prenez du plaisir vous êtes
bien sûr le premier à l'écrire aussi
clairement vous prenez du plaisir et ce
plaisir génère chez vous une certaine
culpabilité parce que vous dites
finalement je prends du plaisir donc
vous avez un tour de ça moi c'est plutôt
évité cette culpabilité vous amène à ne
pas en parler autour de vous ni à votre
père né votre meilleur oui et puis alors
il ya la culpabilité et puis elle fait
aussi que pour moi tous les adultes soit
un peu complice c'est à dire ils sont
tous en vie sa famille devant pareils
c'est un ami de mes parents ils
travaillent tous ensemble et c'est donc
à qui je vais aller en parler
ouais à personne je vais en parler à mes
copains de l'école je vais pas en parler
non plus aux adultes puisque les adultes
sont tous ensemble qu'ils sont plus au
courant
les [ __ ] c'est ça ouais alors vos
parents sont divorcés lui évidemment il
en profite pour s'immiscer comme ça
auprès des enfants et ce qui est
terrible quand on lit le bouquin c'est
qu'on se rend compte que vos parents
sont presque soulagé parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une époque très edonys
très individualiste très égotiste où on
se dit finalement voici s'occupe des
mômes tant mieux dans vos parents bon
ils savent rien d'abord et ensuite ils
sont pas mécontents que ce gala vous
prennent en charge
non parce qu'il avait des tas d'autres
choses à faire mon père était dans une
sorte de vertige incroyable il venait de
fonder sa troupe sa troupe avait un
théâtre national d'un seul coup de
données par le ministère de la culture
il est plein d'argent il pouvait monter
tout ce qu'ils voulaient britannicus
nike presse et caetera donc lui il était
parti dans son truc de théâtre
subventionné
comment on dit délocalisé enfin 2e
de théâtre et puis ma mère elle l'avait
ses amants il fallait qu'elle refasse sa
vie etc et votre mère votre mère ce
qu'elle est mais sait séduire
donc effectivement elle avait toujours
des micros autres mais aussi faire le
porc au caramel
voilà alors avec ce dj bas vous habitez
vous vivez chez lui il achète une maison
pour vous une petite maison là et vous
vivez comme une espèce de petit couple
toujours bas 9 en juin 2009 à 14 voilà
14 ans vous étiez en couple ouais ouais
et ça c'est une photo qui a été fait par
le fameux dj derrière vous et des photos
à la main c'est un bon photographe qui
est une femme aurait alors il en a fait
d'autres qui sont un peu plus suggests
illicit ouais mais que vous n'avez pas
évidemment mais c'est déjà très gonflé
de mettre une photo de lui en couverture
alors vos parents remarquent rien mais
en fait dans la ville on remarque c'est
à dire comme vous avez les cheveux longs
un peu de thym aux aînés vous avez des
pantalons pattes d'eph
vous avez des des chemises indienne on
nous traite de [ __ ] dans la ville on
dirait si le [ __ ] mais vous vivez ça vous
supporter ça bah ouais je suis pour tout
ça et en même temps ce qui est terrible
c'est que en même temps c'était vrai
ouais
en même temps c'était vrai quoi que je
me dis 20 oui ces mecs là ils écoutent
sardou il écoute johnny hallyday
moi j'écoute frank zappa et david bowie
1 et je suis pas je suis pas que me quoi
il y avait un sentiment aussi la fin est
un peu à l'écart d'être mieux que les
autres d'une certaine façon d'être à la
fois nommé pas du tout avec les autres
c'était c'était super flippant
ouais c'est à dire que j'avais deux
copains pour tous en tout et pour tout
j'avais deux copains et donc mes deux
copains 30 ans et c'est pas du tout
d'accord avec moi parce qu'il préférait
la maladie d'amour à de muffin man de
frank zappa donc
il comprenait pas pourquoi moi
j'écoutais cette espèce de musique
bizarre hein
ouais ouais enfin bon il faut lire le
bouquin je veux pas en dire beaucoup
plus c'est très bien écrit il ya cette
idée que vous avez un certain moment de
mettre des phrases entre parenthèses et
en italique et et on comprend que c'est
peut-être ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
en tous les cas c'est raide si un jour
vous découvrez que c'est vous qui le
tenait ouais
hélas cet important segment des
conneries vous aime qu'il est qu'il a
besoin de vous beaucoup plus que ce que
vous avez besoin de lui et vous finirez
par le quitter mais quand vous le
quittez vous êtes tellement détruit par
part dans cet amour
bizarre que vous sombrez dans le lsd
dans l'héroïne
bah non un nom à 15 ans à 15 ans ouais
non à 15 ans à 15 ans effectivement je
prends pour la première fois de
l'hérault du lsd plein plein de drogue
très différente etc
et je trouve ça super bon parce que
parce que ça me fait partie et
je dirais pas qu aujourd'hui devant tout
le monde que c'est super bon mais pour
pour moi ça a été une espèce de oued de
libération en même temps je ne le
recommande à personne
sans la drogue c'est au début on en
prend pour être bien qu'il ya
probablement pas eu à attendre donc
encore pas être mal et puis après on est
très mal on connaît l'histoire mon cher
ami voilà alors là vous vous demandez
effectivement est ce que vous êtes
pédophile parce que souvent les
pédophiles réplique est serein subi ce
qui était le cas d'ailleurs de didier
qui un jour vous amène sur les lieux de
son enfance et vous découvrez qu'en fait
il a été violentée et enfants vivent
peut-être que je suis pédophiles
peut-être que je vais refaire les mêmes
choses à des jeunes enfants vous tenez
vous vous demandez vous êtes homo vous
dit peut-être que je suis homosexuel
après toutes ces expériences et vous
vous rendez compte que finalement non
vous n'êtes pas homosexuel vous rendez
compte que vous aimez les filles et je
voudrais vous êtes mariés
père de famille faisait deux filles
voilées comme vous dites vous n'arrivez
pas à leur donner un bain parce que
parce que ça vous revient à quoi voilà
oui c'est impossible je ne peux pas
toucher le corps des enfants c'est pour
moi c'est trop que donnait un bénéfice
et un peu similaire alors quand vous
êtes dans la drogue un jour votre père
vient vous engueuler aux gens pourquoi
tu prend de la drogue et vous dites moi
enfin si tu comment tu t'es occupé de
moi et il vous dira compte voulu
raconter vous le raconter à votre père
est effectivement il dit j'ai
l'impression de t'avoir abandonné et l'a
donc votre père vous lui dites mais
votre mère en fait il ya très peu de
temps qu'elle sait l'histoire ya deux
mois qu'elle sait l'histoire voit il ya
deux mois que c'est l'histoire mais elle
a été elle était furieuse elle est
vraiment tombé par terre à ce moment là
elle a appelé ce mec
didier ce jeu en lui disant aux faits
mois des aveux et cetera je veux des
aveux écrits et c est donc ce mec m'a
appelé attaché mois et donc il a eu ma
femme etc
enfin bon et c'est vrai que lui
se fait passer pour le bon samaritain il
a un bagout d'enfer et où il est il et
ça c'est un mec assez extraordinaire non
il n'y pas non non il n'y rien mais en
même temps il veut pas ne peut pas aller
en justice quoi je le comprends ils
voulaient y allèrent injustice ou je
crois que c'est prescrit si il est
toujours dans l'entourage de votre père
votre père sait où il est non c'est mon
père sait où il est mais ça y est il est
plus dans l'entourage de mon père mais
on a été longtemps
trente ans après donc vous arrivez enfin
dénoncer on comprend ça lui pour vous en
arriviez là aujourd'hui
pourquoi ne pas lui en fait de procès
parce que pendant trente ans j'ai caché
tout ça sous un mouchoir jusqu'à temps
que je me retrouve à sainte anne où il
est fou et
où là je me suis dit bon mais tu peux
plus tu peux plus tu peux plus t'en
empêcher de 2,2 masqué quoi c'est pas
mon histoire
question vous avez fait libre pour
échapper à sainte-anne grosso modo qua
non mais disons les choses
ouais ouais ouais ouais quasiment voilà
je me suis retrouvé à sainte-anne
plusieurs fois et donc maintenant c'est
stop quoi je veux je veux plus retourner
j'aime mes envies de ces rigolos une
fois de voir les fous regarder la télé
et puis là tu es venu leur parler tous
enfin bon c'est marrant mais deux fois
trois fois
stop quoi et là vous pensez que seul il
va vous sortir de ça pour toujours c'est
là que vous avez enfermé simple cercueil
de mourenx un petit un petit cercueil
écrit avec des mots à l'intérieur et
puis maintenant la pêche et les jeter
dehors et puis le lit qui veut quoi
ouais bravo enfants quand ils liront les
bases et super g j'ai vraiment du mal à
leur expliquer ce que c'est parce qu'ils
voient le livre alors y voit la
couverture et tubize mais c'est toi
ouais c'est moi et
mais ça raconte quoi c'est une histoire
incroyable jean l'île au trésor
non non non c'est je vais t'expliquer
donc je dois leur expliquer demain
ouais ouais demain j'ai promis dur il
faut considérer imaginer que qui vous
regarde là didier là vous auriez quoi
lui dire saga votre caméra ben cache toi
ouais cache toi arrête un casse toi le
plus possible donc arrête
quoi qu'il a continué après vous bah
ouais mais il avait déjà dragué des
copains à vous qui avez refusé un oui
ouais ouais ouais ouais non mais t'es
pas
c'était pas un amour fidèle un an + wii
en plus obligé le dénoncer à la police
quelque chose comme ça obligé non mais
je reste voilà vous sont numérotées les
femmes - où son nom il ya beaucoup aller
il s'appelle didier non je peux pas mais
mais non j'ai j'ai pas envie de le
dénoncer j'ai un procès ça m'aurait bien
fait plaisir un certain moment mais
maintenant ça y est j'ai écrit ce
bouquin ccc ce qui pour moi et c'est
c'est pour moi une forme de une forme de
procès et c'est plus que ça c'est
vraiment plus que ça ouais voilà dans
tous les cas ça arrive que je vous
conseille très très difficile à lire
mais qui est bien écrit et qui est très
littéraire surtout ouais mais en fait
votre entrée en littérature aussi
ouais c'est bien ouais vous c'est vrai
moi perso je trouve qu'il s'en sort pas
mal quand même
il avait l'air plutôt mais dans ce
fameux trophée pas vu avant mais vous
avez l'air bien non ça va mieux ça va
mieux
qu'à 12 ans bravo merci christophe tison
il m'aider
c'est chez grasset mesdames messieurs
déploie sur deux ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu